yeah this is a tutorial video a little
bit of commentary about the candy crush
coloring candy
it's the new bomb that was released with
this game doesn't exist in regular candy
crush and it's a it's a really effective
one I set one up here I'm gonna have to
pause and skip to a couple different
things so I can show you it because
they're kind of hard to make but the way
that you make them is in the end of a
match five like you look for color bomb
and then you have extra Kings involved I
know on the app page that says that you
have to have seven but you can actually
you can actually make only six or so
it'd be like your you know your regular
straight five match plus one down here
and that would still make the common
candy so you make it and it looks like
this it's a we used to call it the
bubble bomb when the game first came out
but apparently based on like other stuff
we've read they call it the tamarind
candy so it does a lot of different
things it's similar to a color bomb
except for like if I matched it with
this yellow one what it would be instead
of exploding all the other ones off the
board it would turn it to the color that
it is and it looks like this one's
orange so the turn all the yellow ones
orange so that could be helpful in that
you'd be able to make a lot of matches
and a lot of stuff would happen if you
match it with its own color then it
picks a color and changes it to that
color changed all those pieces to that
color but where it's really awesome is
whenever you can match it with other
things I mean this is what makes it
better than the color bomb so I'm gonna
make this stripe and here
hopefully everything will fall down
without that went off but yeah you saw
that when it exploded it turned all
those that color and you can see how
that really had a pretty awesome effect
as far as making lots of other stuff
happen at the same time I only have four
moves left here so I don't know if I can
make another one and probably have to
pause the video and come back to a
different board
you having a party
all right so I just went ahead and
started love the 21 it starts with the
coloring candy in the middle so I
figured this would be a good level to
just show how it works in general
I got a nice color ball up here but I
don't think I'll be able to make it then
all right so no simply this is the
basics of how it works you can it's a
green color but we're coloring candy and
got a red in the blue so you'd want to
look around and see where that would
have the best effect now there's not
very many Reds at all so in this case I
would say go light blues probably a
little better neither one of them is
that good but this is just how it works
so you match it with the blue and then
all the blue candies turn green alright
alright so here's another setup and this
is what I was talking about this is only
one two three four five six twenty six
candies but it will still give us the
color I am Jimmy alright so here's
another one you know there's the August
selection will usually show you
it's good to know what you're looking
for
and part of what's cool about these
voyages it's easier to make him cuz you
have a lot of stuff going on but part of
the seamount cool is that they kind of
go off whenever there's a cascade
trying to get it says another
now we have enough for a while but now I
can just set it up like that
all right so this is I wanted to show
you what's different about the color
bomb and the color ink and when you mix
a car in candy with a with a special
candy it not only changes like if you
did this with a color bomb all the
yellow ones on the board would turn into
rats what's cool about the colouring
candle it makes it better is that it
since this is an orange color in candy
with the yellow wrapped candy it's
actually going to turn all the others
and the oranges into it wraps so you see
how that works
so it's in a way it's like twice as
powerful as the colored Montano
they're both great combos but you can to
see that the young Connor cane is a
little bit better all right so here's
another example of that if I matched it
with this one that would change the
orange and the yellows and the stripes
if I match it with the fish
it will turn all the green squares in
the fish and all of your stats of the
fish there aren't very many orange ones
on the board right now but the board's
got a lot of green so this is I still
like this one better for this kind of
level either one is good I just want to
show you the fish one here at Ferris
you can see how this can be effect
especially on a pop the bottles there
get the bear the string talk to the top
you know that you can see how that would
be super helpful because it'll eat up
all the bottles and everything at once
and here is the bubble or the coloring
candy with the strike
so it's yellow strike and the blue time
tunic so all the blue and yellow on the
board whoa
all right for this last one I just
loaded that for video from our YouTube
channel you can see that when we match a
color in Candia and then tell her bond
something really special are these
all right so this is the last kind of
match and it would be to bubble bonds
together see what happens here
that's pretty cool
I think I'd have to say that's the
coolest match in the game but you know
they're all good if you can make a
bubble bomb and or a coloring candy and
match it with any other special candy as
you seen on the rest of the video it's
pretty helpful and it's uh it's just
like you're making a match 5 to make
you're just like this one you know but
you need an extra an extra candy
involved it looks like a small placer a
tea I hope this helps cleared up you
know we'll have detailed detailed tips
and the guide to go along with this but
I just wanted to show you because it's a
little bit hard to you know especially
the on especially the combo with the
color bottom posted by the bomber I
still want to call it the bubble bum the
coloring candy pesto far gone and two
calorie candies together this really the
best combos in the game
they rare that's and that's why they're
so good so we'll be making more how to
play videos soon make sure if you need
tips at the level you go to our level
guide section and if you have any
questions leave the comment if you found
the video helpful please click the like
button that'll really help me out